You're in my home!
And you're about to burn.
Factor 50 okay?
-Hi. Hello.
-Hello. Hi.
We've got
some really good news.
Good news just for you.
Won't take
too much of your time.
You could be
one of our lucky winners.
That's very kind,
but don't
wanna waste your time.
Oh, you won't be doing that.
But I'm moving out today
and I'm in a bit of a rush.
Oh, okay.
Well, can I just
give you something then?
Okay. Here's how it goes.
We need to know
where Carlton Flynn is.
I understand.
You need
a little persuasion.
Actually. Would you mind?
Thank you.
I think, first of all...
Hi, Mr Sutton?
We have some great news.
Some great news
just for you.
This is a God thing,
I don't believe in God.
Haven't believed
for some time,
so if collecting,
I wouldn't bother.
No. It's not that.
Lucy!
Somebody call an ambulance!
Understudy for Josephine,
where are you?
Right here, sir.
Rerig the ropes.
Nice to meet you.
Pleasure is entirely mine.
Awful about Lucy.
Is it though?
Mum, he's hanging on!
Ray. What's going on?
Why we here?
I remember something.
Remembered what?
This is where it happened,
that night,
before I came to see you.
I was here.